if Boris Johnson had hoped to convince
Emmanuel macron to change the e u--'s
negotiating positional Briggs it and
scrapped the Irish backstop the French
president's response made it clear that
wasn't going to happen after greeting
the British prime minister at the Elysee
Palace macro said the EU would not
renegotiate their withdrawal agreement
and the backstop the insurance policy to
prevent a hard border between Ireland
and Northern Ireland in the backyard no
country in the European Union can
negotiate all renegotiate this agreement
the key elements of this agreement
including the Irish backstop and not
just technical constraints or legal
issues but some genuine guarantees to
preserve stability in Ireland and the
integrity of the single market which is
the foundation of the European project
this is all part of what was negotiated
by the UK and the EU micron did however
back the German Chancellor's proposal to
Johnson in a Berlin meeting on Wednesday
giving him 30 days to come up with
alternatives to the backstop good you
know I was powerfully encouraged by our
conversations last night in Berlin with
our mutual friends and I know that with
energy and with creativity and
application we can find a way forward
for all our businesses and our citizens
this analyst says that EU leaders might
have an ulterior motive for offering 30
days more time leaders may hope that
Brewers junctions toppled in the coming
days because they know Johnson's
majority is very fragile
on Saturday macro will host Johnson and
other g7 leaders including US President
Donald Trump for a summit in the South
of France the meeting with Johnson gives
macro an opportunity to reaffirm his
commitment to the European Union and
coming just two days before the g7
summit it also allows him to send a
message to world leaders including
Donald Trump that when it comes to
Briggs it the EU United and won't you
turn on a whim Mike Ross says that
Britain's destiny is in its own hands if
it leaves Europe on October 31st without
a deal the French president says it's
the UK government that will be
responsible and not the EU Natasha
Butler al Jazeera
Paris